over the keys and moments ago what a  moment we just had here folks Staff  Sergeant and Philadelphia native Ivan  Taunus reuniting with his family his son  right there after being away for 18  months that is his 12 year old son he  had no idea that his father was coming  home for his favorite holiday he is a  patriot missile operator the most  deployed branch in the Army and he knows  being away from his family all too much  that's missing holidays birthdays  graduations you name it but another  surprise for you  his son actually asked his father to  leave active duty so they could spend  more time together  so with that tonight extra special  surprise he is now retiring from active  duty and telling his son so he can spend  more time